what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of Marvel news
to go over including a possible Jonathan
Majors recasting an update on the
Fantastic 4 and Marvel and Disney as a
whole and shangqi 2 shangi 2 is supposed
to come out before Avengers Secret Wars
just so everybody is aware it's a
project that'll be a part of phase six
and a lot of people were asking about it
after I did my video the other day
updating people on the filming schedule
well Shang Chi is not not filming yet
however we do have an exciting update so
let's break everything down all this
recent Marvel news in this video and if
you're new be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news so first
things first let's start off with the
possible Kang recasting and I have to
say that I really like the idea of this
new report but I have an idea of my own
that I think would make it super epic
according to Daniel rpk on one of his
alt accounts John David Washington is
reportedly being considered for the RO
role of King in the MCU meaning Marvel
Studios basically is considering him as
one of the possible recast choices and
they are most likely going to meet with
him soon now most people know John David
Washington from tenant Epic movie and a
lot of people also know that he is the
son of Denzel Washington an incredible
actor that I'm sure most people know now
before we get into the future of Kang in
the MCU I just want to state that I
would absolutely love to get John David
Washington and Denzel Washington both
both in the MCU as a current or past
version of Kang and a future version of
Kang when the Insiders started reporting
that Kang is going to be recast in the
MCU a lot of rumors and speculations and
basically Fan cast started happening
about denel Washington possibly coming
in to play Kang in the MCU stating he
could play a future version of Kang a
more advanced a more mature a more
dangerous version of Kang and I would
personally really love if John David
Washington came in and played a present
version of King and then teamed up with
his father in real life but variant in
the MCU and these are the two new kangs
and possibly maybe even one more who
threatened the entire Multiverse I think
this would be super cool to see on
screen but I think it works story-wise
because I would really like to see an
older version of Kang maybe the original
Nathaniel Richards AKA Kang the
Conqueror played by denza Washington and
then a newer younger version of King
played by his son John David Washington
this is basic basically what they did
with the Council of Kings if you noticed
they had ramut they had the Scarlet
Centurion and they had a mortise now in
the comics all of these are kind of the
same person but clearly these are
different variants but ramut seems to
clearly be the oldest variant of Kang in
that post credit scene for Ant-Man and
the WASP with the Council of Kings so we
know they're going to have to
essentially replace them we're going to
have to get a new Council of Kings so
John David Washington could play maybe
the Scarlet Centurion or mortise and
Denzel Washington could play Rama touch
but either way it does sound like all
the reports that we've gotten from
insiders do state that Marvel Studios is
indeed going to recast King and not go a
different direction with another villain
so it sounds like Kang is here to stay
and John David Washington could be in
the running to play our new king the
Conqueror so let me know your thoughts
about this possible casting choice in
the comments down below would you like
it would you not and would you like to
see him and his father in the MCU
together now an update on the Fantastic
4 according to recent reports they are
rewriting the script yes more rewrites
in the MCU this time for the up and
cominging Fantastic 4 movie according to
Daniel rpk the script is undergoing
another rewrite with Academy Award
nominated The Disaster Artist and the
Fault in Our Stars writer Michael Weber
and Scott not stat these are the two new
writers that have been brought on to
work on the Josh fredman version of the
script for the Fantastic Four they're
working on this before the filming
starts now of course this has some
people concerned Why are they rewriting
the script was it bad before is the
Fantastic for in Jeopardy of being a bad
film well fortunately for us I don't
think that's the case I think they are
simply rewriting it to truly make it
better let me explain they're not
rewriting it because it was bad before
but simply they could have had more
ideas to make it even better than it was
before plus they have officially locked
in the cast according to Daniel rpk and
sometimes when the cast gets in there
and they start reading before they go
into production of the film they could
have different ideas for certain things
and you play off the strengths of the
cast that you work with and you play off
their Vibes their Vibes with the
character and The Vibes with the other
characters as well so perhaps with the
certain cast that they have they might
feel like some things will work better
now or not as well now given the energy
and The Vibes of the cast are giving off
with each other and also I must add for
those who are a little worried Kevin
fige loves the Fantastic 4 this is his
passion project he's not going to let
this project be back and we already know
that he's more involved with this
project than he's been with any other
project in phase four and Phase 5
recently especially now since Bob Iger
and Kevin feige have gotten together and
basically have decided that they are
making some massive changes over at
Disney and Marvel Bob Iger has expressed
that in the past like for the Marvels
there's not been a lot of executive
supervision on the sets and with the
scripts but that has changed now it's
been very apparent recently because Bob
Iger has been very outspoken about this
that Disney has no longer going to
release things that they do not believe
are worth releasing this is why all of
those recent projects from 2024 got
pushed back to 2025 like the
Thunderbolts Captain America Brave New
World Daredevil Born Again Etc this is
also why these projects right now are
undergoing rewrites and some of them the
script has been completely Rewritten
altogether because they've decided
they're not going to put out something
that's mediocre if they're going to
release these films they want them to be
like the past really big events with a
really great story so kudos to Disney
and Marvel Studios for deciding to do
this because I think this is what we all
want better movies better stories even
if we have to wait a little bit longer
to see them and last but not least like
I mentioned we have an update on shangi
2 according to alexp from the cosmic
circus Shang Chi 2 is being written
right now and no doubt that the movie is
going to undergo the same let's say
standard that all of these other recent
movies are going through meaning they're
not going to write something bad which
is great news now shangqi and the legend
of the 10 Rings left us with shanqi
basically becoming a part of the
Avengers and Alex P reported in the past
that Katie is still going to be with
shangi in The Avengers film in this
report Alex P also stated it'll be a bit
of a while before we see him again which
leads me to believe that shangi 2 is not
going to come until after Avengers 5 but
it is widely believed that shangi of
course is going to be a part of the new
Avengers team that would make sense
again based off of what we know about
the ending of shangqi the first film in
fact Alex P reported in the past that if
the Avengers were to gather right now
the members would include shangi and
Katie the members that wouldn't really
be included are the Scarlet Witch and
Doctor Strange and for those who were
asking about Doctor Strange 3 in my last
video haven't heard anything yet about
the process beginning for the film
whether that's writing or pre-production
anything like that the movie is supposed
to come in phase six though it most
likely will come after Avengers 5 just
because we know that filming for that is
going to begin in 2024 and we haven't
heard anything about when filming is
going to begin for dodg of strange 3 but
Marvel Studios of course does have a
plan to make that movie and it's going
to be a very important movie leading
into Avengers Secret Wars and apparently
the Avengers lose an Avengers 5 because
Doctor Strange is not there so that's
all the Marvel news for today please let
us know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below and don't forget to
like this video And subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Marvel news also if you subscribe and
leave a comment you're automatically
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items and some DC items as well
the winner picks one item and we pick
one winner at the end of each month you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
wolf